près de dix mille personnes défilent
dans les rues de nantes pour une
bretagne réunifiée
ils veulent profiter de la réforme
territoriale pour rattacher leurs
départements la loire-atlantique à la
bretagne
la loire atlantique n'aurait jamais dû
être séparés des quatre autres
départements
une option pour le moment écartée par le
gouvernement vous bien que le peuple
gauche sinon des politiciens ils font ce
qu'ils veulent et demande surtout pas au
peuple
ils demandent rien du tout dans cette
foule des militants de tous bords des
écologistes à l'ump du ps à lui dit en
passant par le parti breton ou encore le
collectif des bonnets rouges à l'origine
de ces manifestations
la réforme territoriale de françois
hollande qui le crée de grandes régions
à l'échelle européenne
ce sera tout l'enjeu de la réforme de
notre organisation territoriale de
grandes régions les français ne peuvent
pas attendre
le président frappe un grand coup avec
la réforme territoriale qui remanie la
carte de france en faisant passer le
nombre de régions de 22 à 14
une réforme qui va vite tourner au
casse-tête identitaire
administratif et parlementaires pour ne
découvre pas les régions en fonction du
poids de tel ou tel grand ténor
socialiste
peut-être que le calendrier monsieur le
ministre n'est pas absolument génial
quand la moitié des sénateurs de
l'assemblée sont renouvelables ce qui
est ringard c'est d'imaginer qu'on va
refaire la france en trois journées de
débats nous allons vous raconter le bras
de fer entre le gouvernement et les
sénateurs sur la réforme territoriale un
projet de loi qui touche
particulièrement la haute assemblée
représentante des collectivités locales
aujourd'hui on n'a aucune garantie c'est
rien de le dire sur le fait que ce texte
passe mais la volonté du gouvernement
c'est que le débat ait lieu
c'est que la réforme se fasse mais pas
dans les approximations dans les
raccourcis dans les amalgames
après l'échec cuisant des municipales et
des européennes
françois hollande a besoin d'une réforme
emblématique pour relancer son
quinquennat il joue alors son va tout
avec la réforme territoriale objectif
s'attaquer au millefeuille administratif
une réforme a priori bien perçue par les
français le 3 juin 2014
il publie une tribune dans l'ensemble de
la presse régionale ainsi qu'une
nouvelle carte de france de 14 grandes
régions avec une condition on ne détache
pas un département de sa région
d'origine
hervé le bras et démographes auditionné
par le sénat il regrette que l'elysée
n'est consulté aucun expert ça s'est
tramé dans un très grand secret ou du
moins ça s'est tramé au sein d'un
univers politique très étroit donc je ne
peux pas dire que moi je n'en ai eu que
des échos vraiment parcellaires mais je
peux vous donner un exemple d co à midi
le lundi précédait la décision ce
qu'elles aient été annoncés le mardi
matin le lundi à midi
la région des pays de la loire étaient
regroupés avec la région centre donc zen
grande gloire si vous voulez d'orléans à
saint nazaire et à sept heures du soir
la région des pays de la loire était
mise avec le poitou et on m'a assuré que
c'était sûr c'était acté mais on me
demandait mon avis qui a d'ailleurs été
négatifs et puis amateur j'ai eu une un
coup de téléphone des gens des pays de
la loire avec qui je suis en relation
depuis longtemps ils m'ont dit non non
on maintenant on vient d'apprendre qu'on
restait seul qu'on restait la région des
pays de la loire
c'est donc une indication que ça s'est
fait vraiment dans une précipitation
un découpage fait dans la précipitation
mais l'idée elle n'est pas nouvelle
depuis vingt ans les rapports
s'accumulent et propose de réformer la
carte et les deux arguments phares du
président ne date pas non plus d'hier le
premier à voir des régions fortes de
taille européenne
le second faire des économies en
simplifiant le mille feuille territorial
on peut arriver à une dizaine de
milliards d'euros d'économies
parce que 10 milliards d'euros c'est à
peu près 7% de la masse globale des
collectivités locales la masse globale
des budgets des collectivités locales
c'est 250 milliards mais une étude de
2008 vient tempérer ses propos
commandé par le conseil régional de
haute normandie lui même elle porte sur
l'impact économique de la fusion entre
la haute et la basse normandie
c'est la seule étude exhaustive sur ce
sujet
ces conclusions le mariage coûterait
jusqu'à 15 millions d'euros dans les dix
premières années
la fusion ne rapporterait de l'argent
qu'au bout de 25 ans vous avez des
économies d'échelle liées à une
mutualisation en fait d'un certain
nombre de travaux de fonction mais ces
économies d'échelle
elles sont quand même limité et cesse et
c'est à dire que si on prend l'exemple
des lycées vous avez des lycées dans
basse normandie des lycées en haute
normandie vous allez pas les regrouper
pour faire des économies d'échelle il ya
il ya peut-être un petit peu d'optimisme
sur la mutualisation et les économies
d'échelle qui peuvent résulter des
fusions si la fusion entre la basse et
la haute normandie semble aller de soi
d'autres régions ont peur d'y perdre
leur identité
face à ces craintes le premier ministre
manuel valls et s'engage personnellement
il n'hésite pas à aller rassurer les
élus locaux comme ici à annonay en
ardèche
ce sera donc pour beaucoup de français
un changement mais un changement qui ne
menace en rien aux identités régionales
elles existent nos identités locales les
identités locales ont traversé
l'histoire au delà des découpages
administratifs et elles continueront de
le faire grâce notamment à vous tous et
lui qui savait faire vivre les
spécificités de nos territoires
une france d'abord découpé en
département après la révolution il a
fallu attendre 1954 pour qu'ils soient
regroupés en région d si vous avez
nantes le père des régions c'est cet
homme serge antoine à l'époque jeune
énarque à la cour des comptes
en 1954 il est chargé de dessiner ces
nouvelles entités administratives et
s'appuie sur les découpages de plusieurs
administrations comme l'armée ou les
eaux et forêts un travail qui lui
prendra près d'un an
me suis rendu compte que c'était très
difficile de travailler parce que chaque
administration n'avait pas la même le
même découpage de la france certains
avaient découpé la france en huit
grandes régions d'autres en 25 comme la
conservation des eaux et forêts
avec sa femme aline il va travailler sur
des calques qu'il mettra directement sur
les fenêtres
et si certains mariages vont de soi
d'autres relèvent de critères plus
artificielles comme le trafic
téléphonique
si la lozère téléphone plus à
montpellier et moi marseille je l'air
attaché à montpellier vingt-et-une
région sortent des cartons mais pour
leur père lui même il fallait aller plus
loin
à l'époque j'ai écrit un article dans 59
pour dire attention on fait ça c'est
bien c'est commode c'est rapide c'est
pas coûteux et on mais il faut aller
plus loin et il faudrait regrouper les
régions faudrait qu'ils se regroupent
à l'époque ces régions restent purement
administrative pour caser du pouvoir il
faudra attendre les lois defferre de
1982 et des élections au suffrage
universel direct depuis la récente du
territoire est un serpent de mer
beaucoup de dirigeants politiques s'y
sont frottés et ont échoué comme le
général de gaulle avec son fameux
référendum de 1969
plus récemment en 2008 nicolas sarkozy
lance la création du conseiller
territorial
une des réformes phares de son
quinquennat il s'agit d'une
simplification d'une amélioration
considérable mais ce n'est pas une
solution simpliste c'est une solution
qui fait fi des querelles sans fin et
sans issue entre les pros département et
les pros région ce n'est ni la mort des
régions ni celle des départements c'est
l'émergence d'un pôle région département
doté d'un élu comme un vraiment plus je
travaille puis je me demande pourquoi on
n'y a pas pensé avant
une réforme qui ne verra pas le jour
elle sera supprimée par françois
hollande à son arrivée au pouvoir le 18
juin dernier bernard cazeneuve ministre
de l'intérieur présente sa loi en
conseil des ministres
c'est le premier volet de la réforme
territoriale que contient-il
principalement la carte des régions de
françois hollande et un nouveau
calendrier pour les élections
départementales et régionales
le jour même bernard cazeneuve est
auditionné au sénat chambre par
excellence des collectivités et donc
saisi en premier sur ce texte pour la
première fois le ministre se retrouve
face aux sénateurs
j'ai plaisir à être avec vous quelques
heures après que le texte a été présenté
en conseil des ministres parce que je
sais l'importance que revêt pour votre
assemblée
le ton est courtois mais le message lui
est ferme
ce que nous souhaitons c'est ne pas
attendre davantage c'est prendre le
risque d'essayer
c'est de faire des propositions qui ne
sont pas à solde de tout compte parce
que dans cette assemblée
les propositions ne sont jamais à solde
de tout compte
monsieur grosdidier monsieur le ministre
le ton monte rapidement car les
sénateurs eux ont une autre
préoccupation les élections sénatoriales
du 28 septembre et le texte harry au
pire moment au sénat pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de république et
peut-être de l'état français parce que
même sous l'ancien régime
ça se serait jamais produit comme ça on
a quand même eu
des régions d immense région dont une
qui va réunir le plateau de langres à la
baie de somme et d'autre la rochelle à
bourges qui ont été définies en une
après-midi par les caprices de cours et
non pas par une réflexion approfondie
alors de quoi monsieur le ministre
espère que le sénat pourrait s'exprimer
dans toute sa sagesse pour retravailler
eu cette cartographie et si vous voulez
vraiment vous tenez absolument des
grandes régions et que voulaient les
régions pertinente je vois pas en quoi
le fait de d'éventuellement séparer un
département de sa région d'origine
serait un tabou absolu qui serait
absolument inviolable moi je ne suis pas
du tout ceux qui considèrent qu'il y a
les bons moderniste et les mauvais
conservateur et que les mauvais
conservateurs seraient plus
particulièrement représentés dans cette
assemblée
je remercie
monsieur le ministre bernard cazeau 9 de
son sens de la pédagogie
mais le temps presse le gouvernement
veut une adoption définitive du texte
avant la fin de l'année il demande donc
une procédure accélérée
il y aura bien deux lectures dans les
deux chambres mais sans le délai de six
semaines entre la présentation en
conseil des ministres le 18 juin et
l'arrivée du texte au sénat le 3 juillet
derrière les échanges policés la fronde
s'organise d'un côté socialistes verts
et centriste le clan des défenseurs du
texte
de l'autre une alliance de circonstance
entre communistes ump et radicaux de
gauche opposés au projet de loi
premier grief le calendrier on ne
souhaite pas là d un débat à la hussarde
il faut effectivement prendre le temps
de ce débat y compris un débat public
avec la population sera à mon avis
absolument nécessaire et donc par
exemple nous sommes effectivement contre
les procédures d'urgence le gouvernement
voulait tenter d'imposer pour permettre
de faire adopter compris donc en juillet
a très rapidement un texte comme celui
là autre grief le texte porte sur la
carte et le calendrier des élections
locales mais pas sur les compétences des
régions les sénateurs accusent le
gouvernement de mettre la charrue avant
les boeufs si le gouvernement compte
brand qui vaut mieux attendre l'automne
et le débat sur les compétences pour
faire en même temps les compétences et
la carte dont on travaillera ensemble au
mois d'octobre
non faut fait pas la carte d'abord et
les compétences à preuve
des critiques sur la procédure mais
aussi sur le fond les sénateurs de
départements ruraux s'inquiète plus
particulièrement de l'enclavement de
leur territoire dans ces nouvelles
régions
quand on fait de très grandes régions et
qu'on supprime les collectivités de
proximité
ça pose un problème considérable quand
par exemple le département que je
représente est rattachée à lyon rhône
alpes à 11 heures de train aller retour
ou à 9 heures de route aller retour ça
pose quand même un vrai problème
il ya un autre problème qui est
fondamental fondamental c'est la
représentation des départements à faible
démographie il ya quinze ou vingt
départements où il ya une démographie
faible dans les nouvelles régions
ils sont complètement sous représentés
voir pas représentés du tout d'ailleurs
dans le texte de loi du gouvernement
il y a une garantie d'un élu régional
minimum par département que peut faire
un élu d'un département dans un conseil
régional de 150 élus
le soir même les opposants au texte
gagné une première bataille
ils obtiennent la création d'une
commission spéciale pour examiner la loi
qui va recommencer à zéro le travail sur
ce texte
chaque sénateur peut désormais postuler
pour en faire partie
c'est la première réunion de la potière
donc on va dire le président 1 le
rapporteur le bureau mettre en place le
calendrier d'auditions ce qu'on a que
quelques jours la commission spéciale
représente tous les groupes politiques
au sénat en fonction de leur poids dans
l'hémicycle il y a donc une majorité
contre cette réforme
certains socialistes y voient un moyen
de ralentir le texte il ya toujours des
gens qui font des petites manoeuvres
ceux qui sont contre vous essayez de
mettre des petits obstacles comme ça
mais bon moi ça ne m'intéresse pas la
procédure parlementaire
les obstruction parlementaire mais je
connais ça par coeur on s'en sort
toujours
ce qui compte c'est le fond et le fond
c'est que je veux des régions fortes
dans ce pays après une heure de
discussion l'ump jean-jacques hyest est
nommé président de cette commission
spéciale mais celui qui doit monter au
front c'est lui michel delebarre
le rapporteur du texte est assez
cohérent dans sa démarche et qu'on va
sans doute réussir mais est-ce qu'on
arrivera poussé tout le monde même sens
sepang en garde aux ça va être difficile
à avesnes difficile mais notre on est
tout de même l'assemblée qui représente
les collectivités territoriales boulot
c'est de faire avancer ce type de texte
voilà
et pour cause la commission a tout juste
une semaine pour faire des auditions et
élaborer un nouveau texte à partir de
celui du gouvernement
des auditions qui tourne vite au bureau
des plaintes
et moi ça va se traduire dans les zones
à sept habitants au kilomètre carré
sachant que la moyenne de ce départ des
plaintes concernant la carte bien
évidemment mais aussi le sort des
départements victoire est ce que vous
pensez qu éventuellement la carte des
régions pourraient être modifiées en
sortant des départements de certaines
régions et de départements c'est quand
même le lieu de la mutualisation le lieu
aussi de la garantie de l'égalité des
droits
en filigrane à horizon 2020 le président
hollande a annoncé la suppression des
conseils généraux une mesure qui touche
directement beaucoup de sénateurs
on sent très bien qu'il est très
difficile à chacun de sortir de du rôle
et qu'il a sur les territoires par
exemple vous sentez co2 la comprendre
pour être très clair au delà des
clivages politiques les présidents de
conseils généraux sont sur leurs pas
tous mais la grande majorité mais pas
tous sont sur une position d'
incompréhension par rapport à une
évolution du département
une semaine de travaux qui se solde par
un échec
la commission spéciale n'arrivent pas à
se mettre d'accord sur sa version du
projet de loi par 16 voix contre 14
le texte est rejeté le rapporteur lui
même pourtant socialiste s'abstient
le travail de la commission part à la
poubelle c'est donc le texte du
gouvernement qui sera présenté en séance
la commission spéciale en tout et pour
tout elle a dû faire quatre heures ou
cinq heures d'audition à la va vite
elle s'est réuni 1 jeudi matin et on a
redessiné une carte en trois quarts
d'heure
est ce que vous pensez sérieusement
est-ce que les français peuvent penser
sérieusement qu'on découpe de grandes
régions de cette manière là en trois
quarts d'heure au gré des rapports de
force entre tel ou tel président de
région aujourd'hui je ne suis pas
capable de dire ce qui va sortir de la
séance
on est en train de crisper la totalité
des territoires français et le fait que
même des socialistes votent pas le
rapport ce matin approuve yang le
consensus est quasiment impossible à
faire si on ne laisse pas plus de temps
aux territoires
dans les territoires aussi la bataille
s'organise en picardie c'est le conseil
régional lui même dirigé par le
socialiste claude gewerc qui fait
campagne contre le projet de loi
on nous dit vous allez vous marier avec
champagne ardenne et les picards 10 bat
nous sommes picard et nos cousins
germains sont les ch'tis je sens une
opposition très très forte des picards à
aller se marier avec champagne et même
une campagne du conseil régional
largement diffusée sur internet vaincra
picardie on voudrait la faire
disparaître
c'est vrai mais on nous a pas demandé la
permission et c'est non
au sénat les opposants au texte vont
désormais utiliser toutes les procédures
pour bloquer cette réforme d'abord
l'alliance de circonstance entre eux ump
radicaux de gauche et communistes saisi
le conseil constitutionnel et s'est
retiré le projet de loi de l'ordre du
jour
motif l'étude sur les conséquences de la
réforme fourni par le gouvernement
leur semblent insuffisantes en fait
c'était lui l'homme pack qui a
pratiquement rien dedans on peut dire ça
a été fait sur le coin d'une table et
donc nous nous avons dénoncé cela en
disant oui pour travailler mais avec des
éléments fiables
le conseil constitutionnel déboute les
opposants et conforte la position du
gouvernement
vingt-quatre heures de perdues pour le
texte mais ses opposants ne désarment
pas
il y a encore des moyens de procédures
qui sont à notre disposition par exemple
une motion le tendant à soumettre le
texte à un référendum
ça c'est tout à fait possible
c'est d'ailleurs ce que vont demander
les groupes communistes et radicaux de
gauche une motion référendaire pour
qu'elle aboutisse il faut une adoption
par les deux chambres sur prêts à les
défendre les territoires comme
d'habitude le sénat adopte la motion
mais l'assemblée elle ne veut pas de ce
référendum sur la question des régions
cette nouvelle manoeuvre des opposants
au texte échoue est ce que c'est vrai on
fait tout pour ralentir au nom soit pas
tout va changer le gouvernement qui veut
trop bas accéléré
donc on le ferait un petit peu mais
c'est normal ça fait partie du jeu
parlementaire
ce qui m'étonne c'est que certains est
complètement perdu la mémoire
parce qu'on nous faisait puisqu'elle
fois ça faisait trois jours avant de
commencer un texte quand la la gauche
socialiste était dans l'opposition
trois jours il arrivait à nous faire
toutes les procédures les machins les
suspensions tout le quorum enfin nous a
tous fait alors qu'on vienne pas ensuite
nous dire que l'on fait du retardement
le jeudi 3 juillet avec 48 heures de
retard sur le calendrier
le texte arrive enfin en séance au sénat
pour un dernier et long bras de fer en
première ligne bernard cazeneuve venu
défendre sa loi derrière le cérémonial
les deux camps affûtent leurs armes ils
savent que le combat sera rude mais
ignore combien de temps il va durer la
parole à monsieur le premier ministre
jean pierre raffarin s'était pas très
élégant mais c'était surtout une faute
près de nous mêler le secret atteint
chez moi en permanence assurée
auteur du rapport krattinger raffarin
sur la réforme territoriale en 2013
salué par l'ensemble de ses collègues
jean pierre raffarin donne un premier
coup annoncée en même temps la grande
région et la suppression du département
ce sans prendre à la proximité c'est
s'en prendre à la décentralisation
parce que là ya la tribune il va même
prendre directement le ministre à partie
je vous assure que votre réforme
si vous nous l'a confié ou la sortirait
alors que vous même vous êtes
aujourd'hui en situation très difficile
pour sortir quelque chose de positif
imperturbable le ministre de l'intérieur
répond point par point aux attaques avec
ce flegme qui est sa marque de fabrique
monsieur raffarin je n'ai jamais dit que
vous préconisiez la suppression du
département je dis simplement parce que
je suis précis et rigoureux que vous
préconisez qu'on fasse de grandes
régions et que vous dites dans le
rapport ce qui est vrai ce qui est vrai
que ce qui compte pour les régions de
demain c'est leur taille parce que c'est
la taille de la région qui fera la
pertinence de son efficacité
y'a pas de raison de ne pas prendre des
idées qui ont été développées dans des
rapports parlementaires
même s'ils ont été rédigées par des
sénateurs de l'opposition et c'est ce
que nous faisons
la séance se lever la guerre d'usure
commence désormais il faut tenir les
sénateurs quittent l'hémicycle après
minuit ils ne sont toujours pas rentrés
dans le vif du texte et dans les
couloirs les tractations vont bon train
plus pour ceux qui l'auront voté pour le
gouvernement ce sera un ferme
vous avez vu la carte est grand temps la
nuit sera courte pour les sénateurs mais
leur portera-t-elle conseil
le lendemain matin vendredi 4 juillet 2e
journée deux séances et deuxième round
sur ce texte au coeur du débat le
premier article de la loi
la carte le gouvernement maintient la
pression
si l'article 1 tombe le texte est vidé
de sens
j'espère que les sénateurs ne vont pas
s'arrêter à l'article 1er que le débat
va pouvoir aller jusqu'au bout du texte
serait utile pour le gouvernement parce
que je le répète le gouvernement
s'enrichit de tout ce qui peut se dire
au sénat et ce serait utile aussi pour
le sénat de montrer qu'il a envie
d'aller jusqu'au bout du débat même si à
la fin le texte est rejeté comme moi on
en débat totalement
les opposants au texte en décide
autrement après plus de sept heures de
débats sans surprise la carte est
rejetée la carte n'était pas mûre ça
arrange tout le monde de faire tomber
l'article 1 puisque je crois que les
désaccords traverser les groupes d'écran
rentrer dans le détail des défusions ce
que la région centre à l'est avec les
pays de la loire les pays de la loire
avec la bretagne
on voyait tout ça ne n'était pas encore
mûr
mais les ministres espèrent encore
sauver les meubles il reste des articles
a examiné et notamment le calendrier des
élections départementales et régionales
prévues au printemps 2015
le gouvernement souhaite les reporter à
décembre 2015
oui vous souhaitez vous intervenez une
suspension de séance
non oui pour cinq minutes ça vous va
très bien lorsqu on sait qu elle sera
reprise à -25 face à certains
amendements déposés par son propre camp
bernard cazeneuve n'hésite pas à faire
suspendre la séance pour recadrer ses
troupes
pour la première fois le ministre semble
perdre patience
ils organisent un conciliabule dans un
coin de la salle des conférences
les sénateurs socialistes rentrer dans
le rang mais si monsieur le ministre
monsieur présent la commission ne son
collègue la séance et reprises donc il
n'ya pas lieu d'avoir peur
il ya tout lieu d'être assurée puisque
nous avons le temps puisque nous avons
la méthode puisque nous avons les
précautions qui permettent d'éviter que
ne se produise jamais ce que vous
redoutez mais l'opposition au texte
gagne une dernière bataille effet
supprimé l'article 12 exit le nouveau
calendrier pour l'adoption 184 contre
129 le sénat a adopté le projet de loi
relatif à la délimitation des régions
aux élections régionales et
départementales et modifiant le
calendrier électoral
après deux jours de débats houleux en
séance le sénat adopte finalement un
texte sans carte et sans calendrier
je répète un camouflet pour le
gouvernement et la majorité au sénat ce
sentiment de déception de regrets parce
que ne vend pas accompli leurs que nous
aurions dû accomplir le sénat chambre
des collectivités auraient dû pousser ce
texte pourrait dû améliorer la carte des
régions auraient dû avancer sur
l'ensemble des articles
je regrette que on transfère à
l'assemblée l'actualité de ce texte sans
avoir pu la rangée l'améliorer le faire
progresser même si nous avons obtenu
désamorcer certains points mais ce n'est
pas l'essentiel
l'objectif c'est de clarifier les
compétences c'est de faire des grandes
régions
c'était de réaménager l'administration
territoriale nous n'ont pas réussi à le
faire j'ai peur que le sénat soit tiré
une balle dans le pied j'espère que les
gens ne se poseront pas la question de
la cua salle c'est là si nous n'arrivons
pas à avoir une majorité transversale
sur des sujets comme cela
le sénat est libre il est évident que
cela gêne beaucoup
tous les gouvernements quelle que soit
la sensibilité politique de chaque
gouvernement
et pourquoi
il en ai voulu au sénat parce que le
sénat a l'habitude de travailler sur le
fond et d'exprimer sa liberté dans
l'intérêt de la république le sénat a
donc adopté la réforme territoriale
mais un texte vidé de la substance
voulue par le gouvernement
sans nouvelle carte ni calendrier des
élections locales parmi les apports de
la chambre haute tout de même une
meilleure représentation des
départements ruraux dans les conseils
régionaux et un droit d'option pour les
départements pendant ce temps
l'assemblée nationale a avancé et
proposer son redécoupage au sénat
désormais d'imposer sa marque en
deuxième lecture à l'automne une fois
les élections sénatoriales passé avec un
nouveau président du sénat est peut-être
une nouvelle majorité
patrick thomas
mais
dans manière
m
non
chaque année à la pentecôte la feria de
nîmes à sir près d'un an